Most doctors describe high blood pressure as a
condition you have, something fixed that you're
stuck with for life. But the truth is, blood
pressure isn't a static number. It's created
every single time your heart beats, you make blood
pressure. And it changes from moment to moment
depending on your state. And if you can change
your state, you can change your blood pressure,
usually in just minutes. Hello health champions.
Today we're going to talk about the number one
absolute best way to lower your blood pressure in
just minutes. But for this to make any sense and
for you to be able to really use it, we need
to understand what blood pressure is. Why do
we have it? How is it created? And why does
it change? Blood pressure is needed to move
blood. If we have more pressure on one end of
a tube than the other, the blood is going to
move through that tube. That's basically what
it's all about. And the reason we have that is
so that we can move nutrients. So we can transport
nutrients, oxygen, and fuel to all of the tissues,
all the cells of the body. And the strength of
the blood pressure depends on the force of the
heart contraction. It's a muscle that's squeezing
the blood, creating that pressure against the
resistance of the vessels and that creates what
we call blood pressure. And it's usually measured
with two numbers. So the systolic ideally at 120
is when the heart is squeezing and the diastolic
is when the heart is relaxing and filling up
with blood again but the body is maintaining
that peripheral pressure that resistance of the
blood vessel and that's the diastolic usually
around 80. But then the question is the thing
that we call high blood pressure. If it gets high,
why does that happen? What are the factors? What
are the circumstances? Is that a good thing or
a bad thing? And I really urge you to watch this
video carefully from beginning to end because if
you really understand and grasp and apply all the
things we're going to talk about, then this could
be life-changing. If you're just skimming through
and you're looking for what is that one thing,
you can try it and it's going to work, but
you're not going to stick with it because you
don't understand how profound and life-changing
this could be. And blood pressure is regulated
by your ANS, by your autonomic nervous system. And
that's the thing that runs behind the scenes that
you don't have to pay attention to. Autonomic
also means automatic. It does things for you.
And the real purpose is to allocate resources.
It's to decide where does the blood go. The blood
carries the protein and the fat and the carbs and
the glucose and the oxygen. And the ANS decides
where do we send this? Where is it most important
right now? And the ANS monitors, it listens to
your internal conversation. It listens to your
thoughts. It listens to your automatic reactions
to your environment and it listens to all of
the chemical messengers to the hormones and the
neurotransmitters and the chemical messengers and
based on all of that it decides where are we going
to send this blood and how much are we going to
send right in this minute and monitoring all that
is a lot of work. So your autonomic nervous system
is processing billions of bits of information per
second in comparison to the thousands of bits
per second that your conscious awareness is
processing. So you pay attention to little things.
You take snapshots of your environment with your
attention. That's thousands of bits. So your
autonomic nervous system is processing millions
of times more information than you consciously
process. So there's a few different reasons
why your blood pressure could be high. And we're
going to skim over the first ones and we're going
to focus on the second half of this. So first is
metabolic. And it's not that this is unimportant,
but you can't change that in minutes. So if
you have insulin resistance then that insulin
resistance is going to trigger a stress response.
Insulin does that and the basic reason for that
is if you eat food then your body is in a state
of plenty. It needs to process through that food
and for a very short time it needs to increase
circulation, increase blood flow to transport to
distribute all that food, all those nutrients
to the different body parts that are supposed
to absorb them. And that's a normal thing. So
whenever you eat there's going to be a short
sympathetic a short stress response just like
a little bump and then it goes away once these
things are absorbed into the muscles and to the
tissues. Now we go back to baseline and we kick
in the parasympathetic and we'll talk more about
these terms which is the relaxation response so
that now the cells can process this food. They
can manipulate it. They can turn it into tissue.
They can turn it into energy and fully digest
and utilize it. Now that's supposed to be a
very short sympathetic bump. But if you're insulin
resistant, if you have chronically high insulin,
then the brain, the hypothalamus interprets
that as a chronic stress, as a chronic reason,
as a long-term reason to have an increased
sympathetic drive. So that's how insulin
resistance actually drives a stress response. And
it's basically because your metabolism is clogged
up. But there's a second part to this metabolic
function and that is kidney retention. So normally
when we have an increase in fluid volume then
there's an increase in blood pressure. It's
like you're pumping water into a balloon. The
more you pump it, the bigger the balloon is
going to get and the higher the pressure inside
that balloon until it finally bursts. Well,
a higher fluid volume in your vascular system will
result in higher blood pressure. But there's a
normal regulating mechanism here called pressure
diuresis. So it's like a safety valve. Whenever
the pressure increases, water leaks out. So with
more fluid, then there's going to be more water,
more fluid passing through the kidneys. It pushes
itself out because you have these little finger
things that are like filters and more pressure
is simply going to push more fluid out and we're
going to reabsorb less because there's already too
much fluid in the vascular system. So the kidneys
can figure this thing out. And this increased
excretion now results in less fluid volume and
we go back to normal blood pressure. And that is
how it always works except with a few exceptions.
And one of those would be if you exercise for
example. When you exercise your blood pressure
goes up. Does that mean that you get rid of a
bunch of fluid because of that blood pressure
and you have to wet your pants every time you
exercise? No. Because your body is smart. It
knows that exercise is a special case. So during
exercise, it's going to increase the retention.
Even though that extra blood pressure is squeezing
the fluid out, the kidneys are going to reabsorb
more to maintain the same fluid volume despite
that higher blood pressure. So the body knows
with different types of stress, with different
types of sympathetic nervous system activation,
which is the fight flight, then there will be
increased retention. The kidneys are supposed
to reabsorb more of that fluid. And like
we just talked about on the previous slide,
insulin, increased chronic high insulin is also
a form of stress. So therefore, that will also
increase that retention of sodium and water and
therefore maintain a high blood pressure. However,
exercise is a normal form where we're supposed to
do that. insulin is not normal. That's a disease
process or an adaptation that is not good for us.
But in addition to those metabolic reasons that we
talked about, there's also a neurological reason
for increased blood pressure. And short-term,
that's the one that has the greatest impact. And
that is based on your perceived need. when your
nervous system detects a situation where it
thinks, "Hey, this guy is going to need a lot
of extra energy in the next few moments." So, if
you suddenly find yourself in danger or if you're
exercising hard or if you're in a fight, now your
body senses that and it says, "This guy is going
to need to fight or flee." Fight flight. So he's
going to need a lot more oxygen and fuel in the
short-term future and therefore we are going to
dramatically increase your blood pressure and your
blood glucose. So if that happens, if you were a
caveman, one of your ancestors, and you're walking
around and all of a sudden a saber-tooth tiger
shows up out of nowhere, based on experience, he's
a lot bigger. He's got big teeth. you're probably
gonna run and that's the flight portion. And
when that encounter happens, you could probably
increase your blood pressure almost by double in
a matter of seconds because you're just trying to
mobilize that many resources. Your muscle tension
goes up and in the next few seconds, your blood
glucose also goes up. But the key to understand
is that this system is perfect. It's designed for
survival, but it's also designed for very short
bursts of activity. You're not supposed to stay in
that fight flight forever. When that tiger shows
up, you run and either you make it or the tiger is
victorious and you end up dead. But either way, it
was very short term. It's not like today's stress
because your body doesn't tell the difference.
It doesn't really care if it's a saber-tooth tiger
or if it's a bill or a deadline or a rude person
or being stuck in traffic when you have somewhere
to be. The magnitude of stress may be different
but the response is the same and there needs to
be a balance. So we have our fight flight which
is also known as your sympathetic nervous
system. That's just the name of it. It's
the branch of your autonomic nervous system that
speeds things up. And it responds, like we said,
by increasing heart rates, by increasing
blood pressure, by increasing muscle tension,
increasing blood glucose. But it needs to be
balanced by its counterpart, the parasympathetic,
also known as feed, breathe or rest, digest. And
we call it short here para for parasympathetic and
it does all the other stuff. So the sympathetic
keeps us alive against emergencies outside. The
parasympathetic keeps us alive by taking care of
our vital organs and our insides. So digestion
for example and immune function all of those are
handled by the parasympathetic nervous system.
So anytime that we have a significant amount of
stress where we increase our sympathetic function
then the body is going to allocate that blood
allocate those resources to immediate survival. So
as soon as the sympathetic goes up significantly
the parasympathetic is going to go down. And this
is why so many people with chronic stress have
digestive problems and immune problems. They get
sick all the time or reproductive function
or healing. It just doesn't work optimally
when we're under chronic stress. So when we have
this situation with chronic stress, then we find
ourselves stuck and out of control. So let's talk
about what you can control. And this brings us to
the topic of of today's video. Can you control
your blood pressure directly? If somebody tests
you and they say you have high blood pressure, you
go ahead and lower it right now. And the harder
you try, the more counterproductive it's probably
going to be. and it's probably going to go up
because you're trying get frustrated. Same thing
with heart rate. Can you change your heart rate?
Can you lower your heart rate? No, it's not under
voluntary control. Can you make more hydrochloric
acid? Someone says you're not digesting food
properly. Make some more hydrochloric acid. No,
you can't do that. You can't affect your
interleukin 6, which is an inflammatory marker,
an inflammatory messenger. If someone asks you to
do those things, you don't know how to do it. But
what can you control? You can control your breath.
You can consciously change how you breathe. Even
though that is normally under automatic autonomic
control, it's done for you. You don't have to
think about it. You can think about it and
change it. And same thing with your thoughts.
You can direct your thoughts even though most
thoughts are running on automatic by habit. You
can focus differently and change them if you
choose to. And here is the key to understand.
This is so exciting because you can change your
breath and your thoughts that becomes the window
into your autonomic nervous system. Now you have
a way of influencing these things indirectly in
another way. And here is the connection between
your breath and your autonomic nervous system.
When you breathe in, your heart speeds up.
You fire off a little bit of sympathetic,
not like a dramatic thing, but a tiny little bit
of stress response of sympathetic firing. And now
your heart rate goes up and your blood pressure
goes up just a tiny little bit. And why does it
do that? Because whenever you breathe in, there
is more air, more oxygen in the lungs. So it's
more efficient to send a little extra blood
through the lungs when there is more oxygen
there. And conversely, when you breathe out
now, you fire off the other side. You fire
off the parasympathetic. Parasympathetic goes
up, sympathetic goes down, and your heart rate
slows and your blood pressure comes down. And
again, it's smart because when you breathe out,
there's less oxygen. Let's back off a little bit
on the blood flow through the lungs. So you can
increase the efficiency of the system a good
bit with having this built-in mechanism. And
of course this is built in for you. You don't
have to think about that. All you have to know
is when you breathe in, you do one thing and when
you breathe out, you fire off another thing. So
why do you have to consciously change your breath?
Why isn't this genius system taking care of it for
you automatically all the time? And it's because
we are always so busy. We're always so stressed.
The normal quote unquote breath rate is 18 breaths
per minute. If you go to the doctor and they check
your breath rate and you're 18 to 20 breaths,
that's normal. But what does that mean? That
means you're breathing in for about two seconds
and you're breathing out for about 1 second. And I
rounded these off. It's like 1 point something.
So your breath basically looks like this.
And that's how most I exaggerate just a little
bit, but that's how most people breathe. And how
much parasympathetic how much relaxation response
do you think you're going to get throughout the
day if you just breathe out for one second? It's
not enough time for that half of the seesaw to
kick in. So now when you consciously change your
breath and you go down on purpose to six breaths
per minute and you count. So you do this on
purpose and you make sure you breathe in for about
four to five seconds. It's not critical. It's not
exact, but approximately four to five seconds. And
you breathe out at least that long, five to
six seconds. And again, plus minus 1 second,
doesn't matter at all. Just do this and we'll go
through it. And do what feels comfortable for you.
But you see what's happening when you do that is
the time that you fire off your parasympathetic
nervous system, your relaxation response,
your healing response just went up fivefold.
You're firing those neurons off. You're in that
state five times longer. And that allows your
heart rate and your blood pressure to come down.
And then you keep this up six breaths per minute
for as little as one minute or up to five minutes
or even 30 seconds. Even just three breaths can
make a huge difference just to interrupt
what's going on. But the pace of breathing,
even though it's super important to slow it down,
it's not enough. We also have to understand how
the breath works and how to perform it. So,
there's three different muscles in the body
or three groups of muscles that does the breath
for you. Your lungs are basically bags with little
compartment, millions of little compartments
in them. And they're completely passive.
They're enclosed in a vacuum and they only expand
because there are muscles pulling on the tissues
next to them. So the muscles we use to breathe are
called the diaphragm. And the diaphragm is a dome
shaped muscle that sits over your abdominal organs
just like this. And when that muscle contracts, it
flattens out and it pushes the abdominal contents
downward. So when you breathe properly, your belly
is supposed to come out. That's supposed to
happen. Now, unfortunately, so many people are
concerned about their flat stomach that they force
their stomach in when the diaphragm is pushing
down. and now they're kind of short circuiting
the whole system and they're using other muscles
and creating stress. The second important muscle
for breathing is called your intercostal muscles
and costal that's for ribs. That's another name
for your ribs. So it's muscles in between your
ribs. And one way to visualize this is that these
muscles, the ribs are like bucket handles. They're
hanging down off the side of the bucket. And if
you were to raise those handles just a little bit,
then you expand the whole rib cage just a little
bit and it's moving up and out ever so slightly.
So that's what the intercostal muscles do. And
then there is one more muscle group and those are
the accessory muscles and I put them down below
because they're like a different story. We'll
get to that. the accessory muscles, they pull from
the top of the rib cage and from your collar bone
and up. And that's not a normal way of breathing.
That's not what you want to do when you're doing
these types of breaths. So, we'll go through this
in detail so you know exactly how this works.
So for the diaphragm, the portion where your
diaphragm is pushing down and your abdominal
contents are being pushed out, you count to three.
So that first portion is one, two, three. And
during that time only the abdominal area should
move. Your belly should come out. And then if you
wanted to keep going with only the diaphragm, it
would be strained. So then the intercostal muscles
kick in. So when you go to a count of four and
five, now your rib cage expands ever so slightly
and it's going to lift up just a little bit, but
it's not going to involve the shoulders. And then
after that slight expansion of the rib cage, now
you just let it rest for just you could rest for
a second, maybe two seconds, or just a fraction of
a second. It doesn't matter. But there's a point
where you're done with the breath where nothing's
happening. So you breathe in one, two, three,
four, five, six, and it just sits there. Okay. And
we'll go through this a few times so you really
get it. And you can try this as we go. And then
you want to focus on your breath being very slow.
It should be completely silent. It should be so
slow that you make no noise. You should not hear
it because then you're breathing too much air.
This is also not what we would call a deep breath.
It could be a tiny bit deeper than a shallow
breath like your normal shallow breath. Just
go. That's shallow. You can go a little bit
deeper, but it's not a deep breath where you
fill your lungs because now you're kicking in
these accessory muscles and it becomes more
of a forced breath. And then obviously after that
you breathe out. And this is a completely passive
process. That's for a count of 1 through six.
And you take a rest at the bottom when when the
air has left. Then there's a moment where you
have a very brief rest. And this exhalation,
the breathing out is passive. It's just
the elastic recoil. So when you breathe in,
even though it's very gentle, you're you're
tightening up some muscles in your diaphragm
and your rib cage. And when you breathe out, you
just let them relax and they're going to return
to their original shape. And these accessory
muscles, they're important, but not for breathing
exercises. They are for doing deep forced breaths,
like in an emergency or if you take a super quick,
if you sniff in like then that's like an emergency
breath. You see your like the muscles, the tendons
on the front of your neck kick in because those
muscles are pulling the rib cage and the collar
bone upwards. Now, you don't want to do that at
all during this type of breathing because that
is tied to a stress response. When you have an
emergency, that's a stress response. You're trying
to get as much air in as fast as possible, but
that is very counterproductive to what we do here.
And for the people who are supposed to breathe
from their diaphragm, but they're concerned with
their belly going out, so they hold their stomach
in, what usually happens is they switch to using
their accessory muscles instead and they breathe
like this, which is not very relaxing at all.
And another important thing is when I say the slow
and silent and not too deep. A lot of people who
try to do this, they breathe too fast, but they
know they're supposed to keep the in breath for
five seconds. So they just overfill their lungs
and very often they get dizzy and lightheaded and
they say, "Oh, this doesn't work. I get dizzy."
No, you're breathing too much. you're taking in
way too much air. That's why I really emphasize
the slow, silent, and just maybe 20, maybe 50%
deeper than a shallow breath. But it should be
very, very relaxed and quiet and silent. So, let
me show you one more way that you can think about
this. And if this represents a breath, then at the
at the very beginning, which would be at the end
of your last outbreath, there's a slight pause.
It's just a period where nothing is happening.
You're not breathing in, you're not breathing out,
and then all of a sudden the breath just kind
of starts by itself. It's like here, nothing's
happening. And all of a sudden, you notice, hey,
air is coming in. And then it goes up. And now
one, two, three is the only the belly moving. So
I'm going to be quiet and just kind of show you.
So that's the one, two, three. And then we have
the four and five, which looks like your rib
cage just expands a little bit very gently,
very relaxed. And then right at the top here
is again a period where you're not breathing
in, you're not breathing out. There's just
nothing happening. And all of a sudden, maybe
it's half a second, maybe it's two seconds,
you're finding yourself breathing out again.
And you just very, very gently and slowly,
passively release that air. And then at the end
here, which is the beginning of the next breath,
there's a period where nothing's happening. And
then all of a sudden, you're breathing in again.
So, I know this is a lot of technical explanation,
but it's just to try to help you understand how
it's going to work. Obviously, when you're doing
it later, and the more you do it, the more this
is going to run on automatic. And once you have
the mechanics down, there's this little thing
called emotion that can act as a multiplier to the
relaxation effects and to the benefit. So once you
have the mechanics down, now when you breathe in,
you visualize breathing in life or health or joy
or anything else that works for you, that makes
you feel really good, that makes sense to you.
And then as you breathe out now you visualize
breathing out stress or tension or problems.
You could tell yourself in this moment everything
is absolutely okay. I can put everything away just
for this moment. I can start worrying again in
a minute. That's all right. I know I have these
issues I got to deal with, but for right now,
I'm allowing myself not to bother with that. You
could also visualize putting down your burdens.
Like life very often feels like a burden and you
can imagine that you're carrying it all on your
shoulders and then on the outbreath you're just
allowing yourself to put it down just for now. And
usually when you do that, you can feel yourself
sort of getting an inch taller instantaneously.
It's such a wonderful relief. You can also during
this whole process, breathing in or out or both,
you could just silently say the word calm to
yourself or say the word peace to yourself. Other
words you could try is happy or content or bliss,
which means that you just feel good for absolutely
no reason other than that you're feeling good. And
this is very different from how we're typically
conditioned because we're always told that we
should strive, we should work hard, we only
deserve to feel good when we have accomplished
something. So first you work really hard, you feel
really bad, you overcome something and then you
accomplish a goal and then you're allowed to feel
happy without guilt. But the problem with that is
that once you have accomplished this thing,
there's another thing and another thing and
another thing. So if you don't allow yourself
to feel good during the process, then you will
never arrive at that happiness. Happiness is not
something that you get to. Feeling good is not
something you get to. It's something that you are.
It's something that you allow yourself to be. So
you want to change this accomplish in order to
be happy. And you want to change that to happy
in order to accomplish. So once you do these
exercises and you do this breathing exercises,
whether it's for 30 seconds or five minutes, and
you're going to notice with just a little bit of
practice how incredibly effective this is, not
just in lowering blood pressure, but in just
feeling good. And you allow yourself to take that
feeling with you. You will notice that you can
still get things done. You can still accomplish
things. In fact, you do them even better. But the
biggest difference is you're feeling good as you
do them. So, I would encourage you either now or
later to bookmark this and then you replay the
last two slides and you practice the breath as
I described it and you practice with these words
and you practice with these visualizations and
scenarios. And I think you'll find in just
a couple of breaths, sometimes that even the
first breath, you notice how you feel completely
different. So what actually happens now that we've
we've learned how to do it, you may have practiced
and you're feeling good, but what actually happens
in the body? Well, short-term and long-term,
there's some profound differences. So short-term,
the very first thing and dramatically important
is a pattern interrupt. When we feel stressed,
when we feel tense, when we have high blood
pressure, it's because we're in a certain
state. And that state is created by our thoughts,
which usually run in an automatic loop. And the
first thing that your breath, your slow breath
accomplishes is to interrupt that pattern. You're
just doing something different. That thought loop
cannot continue when you interrupt it. And next,
of course, I mentioned that you're going to go
from firing your vagus nerve, your parasympathetic
nervous system, your relaxation response. You go
from firing that for about 1 second up to about
5 seconds. You're allowing it time to kick in.
And as a result, your heart rate will go down and
your blood pressure will go down. For some people,
it's going to happen within seconds or a minute or
three. And for other people, they kind of have
a lot of "stuckage". Their their physiology is
just not that flexible yet. And it could take
practicing this for a few weeks, but it doesn't
mean that it's not working. It just means that
you have to fire more parasympathetic for a longer
period of time. It's like you're chipping away at
something and it's going to take a while before
it gives. You're going to stabilize your heart
rhythms. When they do EKGs and when they measure
your heart function, they measure how steady
the rhythm is and they measure your arrhythmias,
the irregularities, and you're going to find
that all of that gets better. What also happens
is vasodilation. You're going to relax your blood
vessels, which results in warmer hands and feet.
So, if you're suffering from cold hands and feet,
then these exercises are probably going to take
care of that as well pretty dramatically. And
again, it's not going to work if you're sitting in
an ice cold air conditioning rooms where the vent
is blasting on you. You're not going to overcome
that. But if you're sitting in a comfortable
room and you still have cold hands and feet,
then that's not a good thing. that that's a
stress response. That's the vasoconstriction of
stress keeping the blood from flowing through your
hands and feet. You will also notice a decrease
of sweating of the palm of your hand. And for
some people, this is not a big deal. For others,
it's devastating. It can ruin their life. They
can't touch anything because they leave wet spots
everywhere. If they put a hand on a shirt, it
leaves a big hand imprint. It can be that bad.
Some people, they never want to shake hands
with anybody because it's so embarrassing. Or
you see people wiping their hands on their pants
before they they reach out to greet you. Now,
that's excessive sweating and it's driven by your
stress response and it can be dramatically reduced
by these exercises. And you will also notice an
increase in your ability to focus and stay calm
even under stress because you're training your
body to reduce the stress response. And the stress
response is going to allocate resources for you
to run away. It's going to take blood away from
your focus center, the frontal lobe. So, as you
relax, as you increase your relaxation response,
as you warm your hands and feet, you're also going
to get more blood back to your frontal brain and
increase your focus and your calm. And I'll never
forget a teenage kid I had as a patient. He came
in for back pain or some musculoskeletal issue,
but he had all these things I was talking about.
He wouldn't shake hands. He would wipe his hands.
He was a super smart kid, but he did so poorly
on tests. He was getting B's and C's at best.
And he was afraid of meeting girls because his
handers were so sweaty. He was nervous all the
time. So I had him work on these exercises and
within weeks his sweating was down dramatically.
Within a couple of months, he went from a B or C
student to straight A's on all his tests, and he
was so calm and feeling so much better instead of
having anxiety. And again, everyone's different.
For some people, you're going to see changes like
that in a matter of weeks. And for others, it
could take a year. You could have a whole lot
of chipping away to do, but it's still worth doing
it because you're changing things for the better.
Even things you don't notice, you're going to
be improving them in the process. And long term,
it gets really, really exciting because there's
something called neuroplasticity. Most people,
especially the ones who don't watch this whole
video, they're just looking for that 30- second
tidbit. They're going to try this and they go, "Oh
yeah, I felt better, but it didn't last." Well,
it's because you didn't do it again and again and
again. And that's where neuroplasticity comes in.
Neuroplasticity is the ability of your nervous
system to change, to physically change shape,
to rewire itself, to repattern and retrain.
Whenever you learn a new skill, then you're making
new synapses. You're making new connection. Your
nervous system is rewiring itself. And staying
calm and breathing different is a skill. That's
a state in your nervous system. That's a skill
and you can learn it. And in doing this, you're
learning the skill of calm. You're learning the
skill of better focus. But the parasympathetic and
the vagus nerve, it does handle blood pressure. It
will help you lower blood pressure, but it does so
much more. It handles the supply to all your vital
organs. So, as you're doing these exercises,
you're strengthening the vagus nerve. You're
rewiring more in favor of the vagus nerve. And
now the vagus nerve is being fed. It's getting its
information and firing from the cranial nerve 10
nucleus, which sits up in the brain stem. And as
that nucleus, as that center is getting stronger
and growing bigger, now you're improving all the
other things that that center controls at the
same time. You're improving your digestion. You're
improving your ability to make hydrochloric acid
if you need it. If it's low, if it's already good,
you're not going to make more because the body is
smart. your digestive enzymes are going to start
kicking in again. But it doesn't even stop there.
Your immune system is also regulated by the same
mechanism. When you reduce your sympathetic firing
and bring it in balance with the parasympathetic,
your immune system works better. Your reproductive
function, your fertility, erectile dysfunction,
it's all part of the same autonomic balance. your
healing responses, your DNA repair. Every moment
you're repairing DNA, you're getting mutations and
your infinitely smart body is repairing at the DNA
level. But that works a whole lot better if your
sympathetic and your parasympathetic system are
in balance. And at the same time, like we
said, you're going to improve your focus,
your ability to stay calm, especially under
stress. You reduce your anxiety both in the moment
you're doing it and long term if you keep up with
it. If you have less anxiety, if you're more calm,
you're going to sleep better and on and on and on.
And you thought you clicked on this video just to
learn a trick to lower blood pressure. Well, it's
all connected. And in the sick care system, in the
mainstream system, they think all of these things
are separate isolated random functions that you
have to address one by one. If you have too much
stomach acid, if you have heartburn, we give you a
blocker of some kind. If you have something else,
we'll block that. We'll suppress that. Doesn't
work like that. When you address something at the
core, at the root cause, then one thing is going
to prove another and another and another. Because
when things work, they just work. And here's the
best part. The more you do it, the longer you keep
it up, the more permanent these changes become.
Because neuroplasticity kind of means two things.
Plasticity is the ability of something to change.
But they can also make plastic changes, meaning
that we actually lay down more tissue. The
active tissue gets thicker. It gets stronger. It
increases in volume. So all of the brain areas
that support and provide that parasympathetic
output are going to get stronger. The the wires
supplying that information are going to get
thicker. They're going to get more myelinated
because anything that you use more grows stronger.
Anything you don't use, you lose. Use it or lose
it. And this is the magic of neuroplasticity that
most people don't understand. They think, "Yeah,
but I did it for five minutes. I felt better for
10 minutes, but then it went right back." Well,
it's because you didn't do it again and again.
and you didn't do it enough to truly rewire your
nervous system and to lay down those plastic
changes. So, to really make this life-changing,
you do have to also change your diet and your
lifestyle if you're insulin resistant. Because if
you're insulin resistant, that's always going to
drive that stress response and that inflammation
and that tendency for sodium retention and
high blood pressure. So, make sure you take
care of that also. But in terms of the topic
of this video, what you want to do, the most
important thing that you want to do is you want
to pay attention. Notice how you feel. Make it
a priority. Write it down. How am I feeling? Pay
attention. Put it on your computer screen. Check.
How am I feeling right now? And if you're feeling
tense, if you're feeling frustrated, if you're
feeling angry, do something about it. And the what
you do is you take three breaths exactly like we
described. You count to five. You count one, two,
three from the diaphragm. You count four, five
from the intercostals. You rest. And you passively
let the air go out. And those three breaths will
take you 30 seconds. And you cannot tell me you
don't have 30 seconds. Especially if it's going
to put you in a better place where you can be more
focused and more productive. And you do that every
time that you remember and make sure you remember
a lot to check how you feel. You take three
breaths to reset yourself. In addition to that,
you schedule five minutes a day when you can sit
down and just sort of relax and meditate and focus
on these words that we went through. And with five
minutes, you're going to build a whole lot more
plasticity. you're going to build more plastic
permanent changes. But even just doing the three
breaths 10 times or 20 times throughout the day
can be incredibly powerful. And once you got this
going, make sure that you make it a habit. And
then when you make it a habit, you allow for those
long-term plastic changes to take effect. And then
watch your life change. So mark your calendar.
Take me up on this challenge. Mark your calendar
and then you come back in 30 days or 60 days or 90
days and you write a little comment and you tell
people about those changes. If you enjoyed this
video, you're going to love that one. And if you
truly want to master health by understanding how
the body really works, make sure you subscribe,
hit that bell, and turn on all the notifications
so you never miss a life-saving video.